hello everyone and welcome to simply
learns youtube channel today we'll be
taking you through the jquery basics
tutorial this tutorial will cover all
the essential jquery concepts like what
is jquery jquery selectors events and
jquery effects
by the end of this tutorial you guys
will get a basic idea of jquery and when
to use it so before we begin make sure
that you are subscribed to a youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any updates from simply learn
so without any further delay let's get
started
today we are going to talk about jquery
we will go through a brief about what
jquery is and why we use it
before we move on to the installation
part let's talk about what is jquery
introduced in the year 2006 when john
rezik a web developer became frustrated
with the issue of cross browser
javascript he found it so complicated
that he decided to develop the
javascript library of his own to
overcome this problem that same library
is known as jquery today
so jquery is an open source
fast tiny and rich feature library that
makes it easy to interact with html
documents and it allows its users to
manipulate and traverse storm handle
events animations and ejects in much
simpler ways with an easy to use api
that works in almost all modern browsers
in a nutshell jquery revolutionized the
way of using javascript to interact with
html documents
so let's move ahead and see how we can
include javascript in a html file
so here we are in the html file we have
created an entirely new folder for this
we'll save
all the jquery related files in this
particular folders we have two more
folders here one is for the images we'll
be using in further videos and other one
is to save the jquery library file and
we have a html and javascript files over
here fine
now there are two different ways of
including jquery in a html file
we can either use a cdn for that or
download the jquery file and save it
somewhere in a system and then we can
use it later so the former way needs an
active internet connection and for the
latter one the internet connection does
not matter
so let's download the jquery file and
then we'll see how to use
jquery fine we'll move to the jquery
website so go to google and write
jquery.com this will take you to this
particular website this is the jquery
website we have you can see over here
the size of this jquery file is just 30
kilobytes really small right
to download jquery click on this
download jquery button over here
the current ongoing version is version
3.6.0
and the previous two versions which are
one point x and two point x no longer
receives update patches so if you are in
2021 then it's not worth using those
versions click on the button and it will
redirect us to a new page fine so click
on the download jquery button
so here you can see we have different
jquery versions so you can download the
compressed version the uncompressed
development version the map file or you
can also download the slim build
so what happens in slim build is it
excludes the ajax and effect modules
for now what we are going to do is we
are going to click on this download the
uncompressed developmental jquery
version 3.6.0
and you can see we have some code
written over here
the code looks a bit familiar right it's
written in javascript only there are
more than ten thousand lines of code so
this is basically a library with code
written for events animations and many
more things
now press ctrl
s and save the file in your system we'll
keep it inside the jquery folder and
change the name we'll keep it inside the
jquery folder we'll go to desktop here
is a jquery file will keep it inside
this jquery folder and we'll change the
name to
jquery only will remove the version name
from here save it so the file is
downloaded and you can check it by going
through the folder in your system the
file is saved so let's move back to the
vs code and try to use this file in a
html document
to include this jquery file in a html
document we have to follow the exact
same steps that we follow with
javascript files use the script tag and
write type and src and we are good to go
so let's include it here we'll include
the jquery file at the bottom after the
body tag because we want the html file
to be rendered first so what we'll do is
we'll write here
after the body tag
script
src is equals to
so what we have to write here is we have
to write here
jquery we have the file present inside
the jquery named folder we'll write here
jquery.js so this is the path of a
jquery file we'll write it type is
equals to
text slash
javascript
and we'll close the script tag
we'll again do the same thing but first
let me close this for you and
now what we'll do is we'll include the
javascript file as well so we'll write
here script
and src is going to be
jq
dot js so this is the name of a
javascript file
we'll write here type
is equals to text
slash
javascript
fine
so we have included the jquery file to
html document as well as the javascript
file as well fine
we are done with setting up jquery let's
go through a small and exciting example
of using jquery now we'll discuss the
syntax in the upcoming videos you don't
have to worry about it just giving you
an example of what jquery is capable of
doing so if you guys remember from the
previous videos wherein we used
javascript for fade in and fade out
animations we were fading in and out an
image on a button click right and we had
to write 10 to 15 lines of code for
those two tiny tasks so what we'll do is
we'll do the same thing with jquery in
just one line let's find out how
so first thing first what we'll do is
we'll add an image
so we'll add an image to a html file so
here what we'll do is after this h1 tag
will write here img
r c is equals to
images slash
j q dot png so this is the
path of our image wherein we have saved
our image already we'll write here alt
is equals to js and
we'll use the id attribute so let's say
the id is img1 for this image
next up we'll add a button as well we'll
write here button
and we'll do the same thing we'll write
here on click it will call a javascript
function so let's say the function name
is func one
and we'll write here
the button name fine so let's say the
button name is
fade
save it
and here you can see
we have an image over here we can resize
the image by using image height and
image width property here but let's
leave it for now and we have a fade
button over here you can see the fade
button is not working it's just a fake
button for now
so we have been doing all this stuff for
quite some time now right it's easy the
most straightforward task in html we can
say we need to define the function
function now to make the image fade in
and fade out on a button click
so what we'll do is we'll move to our
javascript file
and we'll write here
function
function so this is a function and then
we have the body of this function so
that's simple what we'll do is we'll
write here dollar
inside brackets
will access the id attribute so we'll
write a img1
before that we'll write hash
and after that we'll write here dot feed
toggle
and this is a function
and we'll write a semicolon so that's it
guys we are done with it you guys might
wonder about what we did here so let me
explain guys so this dollar sign over
here is called a selector and it is used
to access an element from the html
document
we'll discuss everything about it in the
upcoming videos so for now just think of
it as the
document.getelementbyid method we were
using in javascript it has the same
functioning
then we have a function named fade
toggle this fade toggle function is
already defined in the jquery file which
we saved earlier in our system
this function fades out the image if the
image is there on the screen and the
good part is it also reverts the picture
if we click on the button again isn't it
interesting
we don't have to write lengthy code for
such small tasks so let's find out how
it works
save it
go to the browser and click on this fade
button
see the image is gone click on the fade
button again and here it is so guys this
is what jquery can do in just one line
the set interval method we were using
previously also has an alternate here in
jquery we have to write the time
interval inside the fete toggle function
and that's it what we have to do is we
have to write here inside the fade
toggle function so let's say we are
writing here 3000 milliseconds save it
and go to the browser here we are click
on the fade button and see the magic
easy and worth using right
so i hope you guys understood all of
this for now
now before we wrap up this video let me
show you guys the second way of
including jquery in a html file by using
cdn
so we have to do the same thing again so
go to jquery.com again and click on the
download button scroll down and you can
see here it says using jquery with cdn a
content distribution network or a cdn is
a distributed network of proxy servers
and their data centers it provides high
availability and performance by
distributing the service related to end
users provided that the user has an
active internet connection
so click on any of them from wherever
you want to download for example
we'll click on the cdnjs.cdn
so we'll click on this and it will take
us to a new website copy the link from
here with script text so if you click on
here it will say
copy with script tag right so what we
have to do is we have to copy the link
from here with the script tags and go to
the javascript file
place it in place of script tag here now
what we'll do is we'll paste it here in
instead of this script tag
now
we have written over here srcs
cdnjs.cloudfair.com and this is the
whole path and then we have integrity
cross origin referral policy and all
fine save it now
go to your program and let's see if it's
working or not click on the fade button
wait for three seconds and it's totally
working right
so in today's video we came across an
introduction to jquery i hope you guys
understood it we are going to discuss
selectors in jquery
we'll go over some particular types of
selectors in this video
we are all aware of accessing an html
element in javascript we have three
different methods for that the get
element by id the get element by class
name method and the get elements by tag
name method so these three methods we
have been using for a long time
apart from these three methods we can
also use query selectors for accessing
css selectors right so let's do the same
task using jquery today
now selectors allow us to manipulate or
access html elements as a group or
single element in jquery
the syntax for accessing any particular
element is so simple that we don't have
to remember all of it just go through it
once and you might remember it for life
all we have to do is to use a dollar
sign and pass the id or class name with
particular symbols to let the jquery
file know the type and that's all
the question that arises here is how it
is different from javascript if we are
doing the same thing in jquery then what
is the real difference between these two
so guys jquery selectors are used to
find or access html elements based on
their name id classes types attributes
values and much more in simple words
jquery provides us the flexibility to
access any element in different ways
jquery selectors are based on css
selectors and it contains some custom
selectors as well so let's start by
going through the simple syntax and you
guys will get an idea of what selectors
are in jquery
what we'll do is we'll create an html
element with specific id first and then
we'll try to access that element so what
we'll do is we'll move to the body part
and we'll write here
div
id is equals
to let's say div one
so we are creating a div tag now inside
this what we'll do is we'll write some
paragraphs so we'll use the p tag for
that we'll write here p let's say we are
writing here this is paragraph one
let's add another paragraph here what
we'll do is we'll again use the p tag
and we'll write here
this is
paragraph
two fine so what we'll do next is we'll
copy this whole div tag and we'll paste
it again basically what we are doing is
we are creating two div tags here fine
we'll write the id as div 2 and here
we'll write this is paragraph 3 and this
is paragraph 4 just for your convenience
guys
now what we'll do is we'll create a
button and we'll call a function on
clicking that button so the same part
with javascript as well what we'll do
here is we'll write here
button
and here we'll write
on click
so after this we'll write
let's say we are creating a function
named function this button click will
call this function and
let's say
the button name is click me fine
what we did here was simple we have used
two div tags and four paragraph tags
over here now we'll make some styling
changes here in both the div tags so
that they'll look different from each
other we have already added the style
sheet here we have the link as
stylesheet and the href is style.css so
this is a css file we'll make some
styling changes to our div text from
here so before that let's save this
program once and check the output so
here are our paragraphs we have
paragraph one two three and four so all
of these paragraphs are present inside
two different div tags
we are not able to see those div tags
but we have used them here so what we'll
do is we'll make some styling changes to
make them look different
so you can see the click me button is
not working as of now now what we'll do
next is
we'll go to style.css and
we'll start styling those div tags we'll
write here
hash
div one
so we'll style d1 first we'll write here
margin
as auto
let's say
text align at the center
border we are going to add we'll write
your border
as three pixels black and
dot it fine
next up we'll write here
font size as 50 pixels let's say
and the background color is going to be
let's say credit blue fine
next up we'll write here
height so
let's define the height of this div tag
we'll write a height as
300 pixels
and
width has 300 pixels fine now we have to
write one more thing here the position
is going to be
relative
and save it here you can see we have a
div tag over here so you can see the
font size is quite large what we'll do
is we'll reduce the font size here let's
say the font size we are going to write
here as 30 pixels so now you can see
it's working totally fine we have two
paragraphs inside a particular div tag
we have two paragraphs inside a
container what we'll do next is we'll
copy this piece of code
and we'll do the same thing for the
second div tag right we'll write here
div two save it and here you can see we
have two div tags over here
now what we'll do is we'll change the
color of this div tag fine
let's say the color of this div tag is
yellow
save it and here you can see we have two
div tags over here right here
margin top is
10 pixels
fine save it and here you can see they
are not touching each other now now we
are done with styling our div tags
according to our need you can check it
by going through the webpage and here
you can see we have both our boxes
present over here so let's move on to
the jquery part now and we'll try to
make some changes in the styling of
these div tags using jquery selectors
so we'll move to a javascript file
first of all we'll access both the div
tags here we'll try to make some changes
in both the boxes using the element name
so we have to create a function named
function here so first of all we'll do
that we'll write your function
function
and inside the body of this function the
next thing we have to do is to change
the style of these div tags right so the
jquery syntax goes like this we'll
define the syntax first so it goes like
dollar
then we have the element name
so a dollar sign followed by an element
name
now the javascript alternative for this
statement will be
document dot
get element by tag name and then we'll
write here the
element name fine so this is the
alternative of this particular statement
in javascript you can check if it's
right or not
so you can see here it's showing some
error because we haven't written the
original element name here so it's
totally fine
now once we are done with this part we
have to mention here the action as well
in the jquery syntax
so the actions here may be predefined or
we can customize those functions as well
for now we'll use the predefined actions
so let me tell you the syntax first
we'll write here action so action is
going to be a function which will
perform certain
task in the
div tags fine
now let's move on and write the actual
code here
now in this particular case we are
accessing the div tags here so we want
to make similar changes to both the div
tags right what we can do is we'll write
here
dollar
inside this
we'll write the element name inside
double quotes and
after that we'll
write the action name so we'll write
here dot css and inside css we'll write
here
background
color and after this we'll define the
color here
so let's say the color is orange let's
say so let's define them inside single
inverted commas
and
we are good to go
now what we did here is we selected both
the div tags we have to put the element
name inside the double quotes then we
have the action as css that will allow
us to make styling changes in the html
elements then we have defined the style
changes inside the brackets here what we
are doing is we are changing the
background color of both the div tags on
the button click to orange
so
let's save it and what we'll do is we'll
click on this click me button and see if
it's working or not so click on it and
you can see the color is orange for both
the div text
you can see it again we'll refresh this
page click on this click me button and
you can see the color is orange now
fine so this is how we can access all
the elements from an html file using the
element name only it is an alternative
to get element by tag name fine
now let's suppose we want to make
changes to a particular paragraph let's
say paragraph 1 only in javascript we
can do it with the help of
document.getelementbyid method in jquery
we can also use the id attribute to do
so so let's suppose we want to change
the font style of paragraph 1 only we
want to change it to italic so we'll do
it with the help of jquery so what we
have to do is we have to provide the
paragraph tag and id first so we'll move
to html file
here is the html file and this is the
paragraph one we'll use here id as
p1 for this paragraph
save it now
and now what we'll do is we'll comment
this piece of code
and we'll write here again
dollar so we are using the id attribute
so we have to use hash here
we'll write here p1 dot css is the
action name
and inside this will write
font style
and the font style is going to be
italic
fine
so we have to close this bracket over
here
and we have to remove this bracket from
here fine the thing to notice here is we
have to include the hash symbol before
the id attribute while accessing any
particular id save it
go to the browser and click on the
button over here and you can see the
font style of the paragraph is changed
to italic now see the same thing we can
do with get element by id method as well
it's straightforward right now the
question is what if we have two elements
with the same id and we want to change
the style of both the elements in jquery
it doesn't work in that way so what
we'll do here is we'll move to a
html file and we'll give this paragraph
3 the same id so what we'll do is we'll
write here ids p1 save it now and let's
see if the font style for paragraph 3
changes or not on the button click
so on clicking the button over here you
can see the style does not change it
means that jquery needs the id to be
unique for each element fine
so the other alternative to do so is to
use the class attribute in place of id
attribute we'll do the same thing
instead of using id as p1 what we'll do
is we'll write here
class so let's say the class name is
para for paragraph one and for paragraph
three
we'll use the same class name we'll
write here para
now let's try to access both the
elements using jquery selectors so we'll
move to a javascript file again and
we'll comment this
statement and over here what we'll do is
we'll write here
dollar
element name so we have to write here
the class name with the dot symbol
then we'll write here
dot css
and we'll write here
fonts
tile as
italic
fine
now save it
click on the button over here and you
will be able to witness the change in
the web page so you can see it's not
working
we have done something wrong here
so let's check it out once
we haven't saved the html file i guess
so we'll save the html file
we'll save the javascript file and we'll
click on this click me button you can
see the change in the web page now
now you can see how we are able to make
changes in both the paragraphs at the
same time so this is how we can use
jquery selectors we covered three
different types of selectors the id
class name and element name selectors
so let's go through some more types of
selectors today let me tell you guys
what selectors are in jquery again to
revise what we have done till now
selectors allow us to manipulate or
access html elements as a group or
single element in jquery based on their
name id classes types attributes values
and much more in simple words jquery
provides us the flexibility to access
any element in different ways
the previous three selectors are easy to
understand and i hope you guys must have
gotten the idea of how they actually
work in jquery
if you haven't watched the previous
video on jquery selectors i recommend
you to go through it as we'll be using
the same code we have used for those
three selectors
so let's start with our first selector
of the day
over here you can see we have the code
from the previous video wherein we
created two different boxes and made
some style changes using jquery
selectors and actions
if you see here we have used jquery for
selectors and we are performing certain
actions right so if we click on this
click me button you can see the font
style changes to italic for both
paragraph 1 and paragraph 3.
so what we'll do now is we'll add
another box here with different content
like let's say we are adding a list of
items or something so for that we'll go
to our html file and we'll write here
after this div tag we'll create another
div tag so inside this particular div
tag what we are going to do is we are
going to provide the id as
let's say
div 3 to this particular div fine
now inside here what we'll do is we'll
use an ordered list and then we'll use
list element fine so
here what we'll do is we'll write item
one and we'll copy this piece of code
and paste it again for five times so
let's change the item name to item 2 3 4
and
5. save it and you can see here we have
a list of items on our web page so let's
style this div tag as well to look
almost the same as the other two
containers so what we'll do is we'll
move to our css file we'll copy this
piece of code for div one
and we are going to paste it here fine
so what we are doing is we are basically
using the same code we are styling the
element the same way we did for previous
two div tags fine save it now and here
you can see we have three boxes over
here we have three containers over here
the first two containers contain four
paragraphs and the last container
contains a list of items
now we are done with both html and css
parts so let's move on to the jquery
part now
now let's suppose we want to make
changes in the first two containers only
or in any two containers let's say we
want to change the background color of
the first container and the third
container to green
and we have used the same class for the
first and second container let's do one
thing we'll move to html file and you
can see over here we have the first div
tag with class as div with two v's and
then we have another div tag with the
same class so the third one does not
have any class for that right
so in that case we can't use the element
name to do so because if we use the
element name for making changes then
those changes will be visible in all the
three containers we can use the class
name but we have used the same class for
div one and f2 so it's impossible
what we can do here is we can use the id
attribute because we have unique ids for
both the div text for div 1 and div 3.
now jquery allows us to make the same
changes in one or more elements using
the id attribute only
so the task is simple what we have to do
is we have to go to a javascript file or
jquery file we can say we'll comment
this statement for now and we'll write
here dollar
and inside brackets will pass the id
attribute so we'll write here given
comma
div
and
we have to put here the hash symbol
because it represents the id of any
element so we'll write here dot css and
inside this will write
background
color and the background color is going
to be
green
fine
that's it guys what we have to do is we
have to separate the ids with the comma
and we can make changes to several
elements at the same time
save it
and click on the button over the browser
so what we'll do is we'll reduce the
size a little bit so that both the
containers are visible so you can see
the first and the third containers have
same colors over here so let me first
change the color of the third container
we'll go here and we'll change the color
to let's say
gray fine save it and you can see all
these three containers has different
colors so what we'll do is we'll save
this piece of code and we'll click on
this click me button and you can see the
containers with id 1 and id 2 the color
is changed to green so what if we want
to do the same thing for the third
container and the first container so if
we write here div 3 instead of div 2
save it now click on the button and you
can see the color is changing for both
the containers so it's working totally
fine not only that but instead of using
multiple ids we can also use different
attributes at the same time like we can
use the class name and the element name
here as well so let's say if we write
here let's comment this piece of code as
well
and we'll write here in the next line
dollar
let's suppose we are writing here
given so this is the id for the first
container so we are using the hash
symbol so remember it is a id and right
here we are writing
li so li is the tag name and we are
using tag name over here so what we'll
do is we'll write here css
and then we'll
change the background color
and the background color is going to be
let's say purple fine so we are done
with it save it and click on the click
me button you can see
the color of both the elements changed
at the same time
this is one of the reasons to choose
jquery it provides us the ease to work
on multiple attributes at the same time
the color of the first container and the
color of the list elements changed
simultaneously here
so we can also make changes to the
particular element present inside the
specific div tag for example let's say
we have two more paragraphs outside the
div tag so let's add them first and what
we'll do is we'll move towards html file
we'll copy this piece of code from here
and we'll paste it
here after the h1 tag
fine now what we'll do is we'll change
the paragraphs
so let's say the paragraph one says
this is paragraph one
outside
div tags fine
we'll do the same here as well we'll
write here outside
div tags save it now and you can see
over here we have two paragraphs over
here what we'll do is we'll remove the
second container from here
so let's do it
and save it now
we'll remove the styling as well for the
second container
save it now we have only two containers
over here and we have a click me button
fine
now what we want is we want to make some
changes to the paragraphs present inside
the first and the second containers we
can't use the element name because it
will make changes in all the paragraph
elements so what we can do here is we
can write here
we'll move to our javascript file and
we'll write here
dollar and inside this we'll write
div
greater than sign and we'll write here p
now we are going to use here
fate toggle
so what we did here is we asked jquery
to make changes to the paragraph
elements present inside the div tags we
have also used the fate toggle action
here to make it more clear to you guys
the syntax is simple we have to pass the
parent element with a greater than sign
and then the element name in which we
want to make changes so let's see if
this statement is working or not
save it move to the browser click on
this click me button and you can see the
paragraph is completely hidden
right you guys don't worry about the
actions for now because we'll cover them
in the upcoming videos although they are
not complicated but still if you are
thinking about them then don't worry we
are here to help you with that
this statement can also work without the
greater than sign just like it does in
the css properties so let's see if it
works or not after removing this greater
than sign save it now you can see the
paragraphs are here and we want to fade
them out on button click so click on
this click me button and you can see
it's working totally fine and if we
click on this click me button again you
can see the paragraphs are here
next up what if we want to access the
first paragraph only
now we are talking about this particular
paragraph so what if we want to access
it
we can't use any of the selectors we
have been through till now it does not
have any id or class and we can't use
the element name because that will make
changes in all the paragraph elements
for that what we have to do is we have
to write here
dollar
and after it will write
p
colon
first fine then we'll write here fate
toggle and we'll call this function
so we are done with it this statement
will access the first paragraph element
from the whole html document
save it click on the button and you can
see on clicking the button the paragraph
one is completely hidden click on the
button again and the paragraph is here
again
but will it work the same way if we
write second in place of first like if
we only want to access the second
paragraph not the first one so let's try
doing it
and it will be easy for you to
understand so we'll write here second
now what we want is we want to access
this particular paragraph save the
program move to browser click on this
click me button and you can see it's not
working you can go through the inspect
elements and you'll find an error over
here
so if we go to console you can see it
says
unsupported pseudo second so it does not
supports this so we can do it for the
first
element present in the html file only so
we'll write here first again
save it now and you can see it's working
now
we can do the same thing with the class
name id or the element name what else we
can do here is we can make changes in
the odd and even elements as well so
let's suppose we want to hide the list
item present at odd numbers for that we
have to write a simple code so what
we'll do is we'll comment this as well
because
if you want to check it later you can
check it from here that's why we are
commenting all the statements so what
we'll do here is we'll write here
li
and we'll write here after colon even
fine
then we'll write here
fade toggle
save it click on the button over here
and the list elements present at 0 2 and
4 are gone because even numbers start
from zero
that's why the item one three and five
are gone and the item two and four are
present at odd places now we can do the
same thing for odd elements as well so
for that we have to write here
odd in place of even save it now
click on the click me button and you can
see the items 2 and 4 are gone now of
course they'll reappear on the screen if
we click on the button again that's
because of the fade toggle method we
have used we are going to discuss events
in jquery
we'll go through an introduction to
events then we'll cover some particular
type of events in this video as we have
completed javascript before jquery so i
hope you guys must know by now the
definition of events so the simple
explanation of an event is something
that happens
like when we manipulate an html document
in javascript we try to do something on
the web page right several events take
place on a website like
the user hosts over specific elements or
click on an element pressing a key in
the website can also refer to an event
or submitting a form or playing a video
also refers to an event in a website so
this is the basic definition of events
so let's go through an example of
javascript events and we'll see what
they actually are
we'll create a button for calling an
event and then we'll do same sort of
stuff with jquery as well so let's do it
with javascript first so first of all
what we'll do is we'll write here
we'll add an image on our browser so
we'll write here img
src is equals to images the image is
present inside the images folder and the
image name is
j1.png
then we'll write here alt and alt is
going to be
javascript fine
let's give it
an id as well so we'll write here ids
img1 for this img tag and then we'll
create a button over here so we'll write
here button id is equals to let's say
btn
and then we have
on click event so we'll call a function
on clicking the button so we'll write
here
function function
and then we'll
close this tag so let's say the name of
this button is click
fine
we are done with it save it so the image
is quite large so what we'll do here is
we'll change the size of this image so
we'll write here width is equals to
let's say
250 pixels fine save it now and you can
see the image size is fine now so what
we did here was a primary task we have
added an image and we are calling a
function using the on click event it
means that if the user clicks on this
button then something will happen and
for now that something depends upon us
and we'll define it after this so
basically something will change in the
web page on button click fine so let's
define this function now first
so we'll move to a javascript file this
is a javascript file and we'll write
here
function
function fine so we have to define this
function so what we'll do is we'll write
here document
dot get element by id and id of images
image
1 i guess let's confirm it once so the
id of
image tag is img1
and then we'll write here dot
style dot width so let's say we are
changing the width of this
image on
clicking the button so we'll write here
let's say
500 pixels
fine this is the size we want to change
save it now that's it so we are doing
all this to give you guys an idea of
what events are in jquery and how they
are different from events in javascript
so this button click over here is
basically an event if we move to html
file and see here so this on click over
here is
actually an event and this event will
call function1 so the function1 we have
defined in a javascript file and this
function1 will change the width of this
image fine i hope you guys understood it
so what we'll do now is we'll save this
piece of code we'll go to the browser
and click on this button so click on it
and you can see the image size is large
fine you can refresh it you can click on
it and the image size is large we can
also revert the changes by creating
another function here like we'll write
here function functo and then we'll give
the original size and on clicking
another button the image will get back
to its original size so we can do it but
we'll not do it as of now
now
similar events are present in jquery as
well the events and functioning remain
the same the only thing that changes in
jquery events is the way of calling an
event so the syntax in jquery goes like
this
so what we'll do is we'll remove this on
click button from a html file
we'll remove this on click event from
here and now this button has an id btn
and it's actually a button now what
we'll do here is we'll comment this
piece of code
because we want you guys to see the
difference in
both events in javascript and jquery now
what we'll do is we'll write here
dollar
inside this will access our button so
we'll write here button button is the
element name we are not using the id
attribute here of course we can write
here hash btn as well so we'll write
here
dot
click and what we'll do is we'll create
a
function name so we will write here funk
one and the next thing we are going to
do here is we are going to create this
function we are going to write here
function func one and the rest of the
things will remain the same so we'll
write here dollar will access the image
so we'll write here
hash img1
and then we'll write here dot css will
pass here width
and the width is going to be
500 pixels fine
fine so we are done with it this click
function over here so if you see here
you can see this click is a function
basically so this click function over
here is actually a predefined function
in the jquery library that will be used
to perform a specific task on the web
page
save it save the program now move to the
browser click on the button and you can
see the size is changing we can also use
the concept of anonymous function here
in place of creating a whole function
like if we don't want to write here func
one and then we don't want to create
another function what we can do here is
we can write here
dollar
button and then we'll write here dot
click
inside this will write function
this is the body of this function
we'll put semicolon over here and we'll
copy this statement from here fine
now comment this piece of code
and here we have used the concept of
anonymous function fine it's quite
simple so save it
and click on the button
you can see it's working totally fine so
this was just a tutorial of how we can
use events in jquery so this is
basically an introduction of events
now next up we'll be going through an
event that will be needing every time we
are using jquery so what we are going to
do is we are going to write here
dollar and we are going to access
document so this document refers to the
whole html document
and then we'll write here
ready and then we'll write here a
function so we'll
create a body of this function
now
the ready function will be called after
the html documents is fully loaded what
we want to do is we want to keep the
jquery part in a queue until the
document is being loaded so for example
let's say we have a big website with so
many buttons and different things
present inside it
now the button will perform some actions
on clicking right let's say the user's
internet speed is not adequate and the
button loads before anything else on the
web page it will affect us right like if
the user presses the button before
anything loads in the web page then
there's no way of writing any jquery for
that right we can't do anything for that
so what we want is we want the html
document to be loaded fully before the
jquery part works so for that we use the
ready event so red is basically an event
in jquery so make it a habit of using
the ready event guys it is considered a
good habit by programmers across the
world so what we have to do is we have
to put
this code in a jquery part or javascript
part and then we have to write anything
inside of it so what we'll do is we'll
cut it from here we'll paste it here and
let's remove this for once so this is
how our javascript file will look like
after including the ready event in a
website so what we have to do basically
is we have to include the ready event in
our javascript file and then we have to
start writing code for other events as
well we'll cover the remaining events in
jquery and we'll see how they are
different from javascript events
we have been through certain types of
events in the previous part
we have an idea of how to call an event
in jquery and how to use the on click
event to manipulate the html element
so we'll use the same code in today's
video as we'll be going through some
more types of jquery events and you guys
will have an idea of several jquery
events by the end of this tutorial so
let's start with the first event of the
day if you guys ever notice that some
buttons work on double click only in
javascript we use on double click for
such events now jquery also supports
such events so in jquery instead of
using double click or on double click
what we have to do is we'll go to this
code and we'll write here
double click only that's it so this is
the event and this is the function we
have created so what will happen is on
double clicking this button this image
size will change to 500 pixels rest of
the part will remain the same now i
suggest you guys to watch the previous
part because we have been using the same
code so i hope you guys have watched
that part before going through this
video so what we did here was we changed
the name of click event to double click
only and the rest will remain the same
now save the program go to browser and
click on this button over here you can
see the button is not working on
clicking it now double click on it and
it's working totally fine right so this
is how we can use the double click
jquery event
now the following events we'll cover are
the mouse enter and mouse exit events if
you guys remember from the animations in
javascript video wherein we were
changing the animation on mouse over
then you must have noticed that we are
using the on mouse over and on mouse out
events right so the same events with the
same task we have in jquery as well
the names are mouse enter and mouse
leave
so here the mouse enter event represent
the on mouse over event and the mouse
leave event represents the on onmouseout
event
now the rest of the things will remain
the same what we'll do here is
let me just remove this piece of code
and we'll write this code again so we'll
write here
dollar
and then we'll access our image so this
is the id of our image so we'll write a
hash
img1 and then we'll write here
mouse enter
and then we'll create a function over
here
so function totally depends upon us we
can create an anonymous function or we
can create a separate function as well
so what we'll do here is we'll write
here inside this function
dollar and will again access this image
so we'll write here img1
dot
css and then we'll pass the styles over
here we'll write here width and we'll
change the width of this image to
500 pixels
fine
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write the code for mouse leave event as
well so if you save this program for now
and you can go over here on the browser
and hover your mouse cursor over the
image you can see the size is changing
now what we'll do is we'll write the
code for mouse leave event as well so
for that we'll write here
dollar
and then we'll access the image again
we'll write here mg1
dot mouse leaf
and then we'll create a function over
here so we'll write here function and
the function will be responsible for the
change in size of this image so we'll
write here dollar
then we'll again access the
image so we'll write here img1
then we'll write your dot css and then
we'll write here
width
is going to be again to the default ones
so the default width is i guess 250
pixels let's check it out over here
so if you can see here the width of this
image is 250 pixels right so what we'll
do is
we are done with it we'll save this
program
and now go over to the browser you can
see that the image size increases on
taking the mouse cursor over it and the
image gets back to its original size on
taking the mouse cursor away from it
so simple and so easy right
now there exists a common event that can
act like both the mouse enter event and
the mouse leave event so the whole event
is used to do so it takes two arguments
and the rest will remain the same so
what we'll do is
we'll comment this piece of code for now
and we'll write an alternate code for
this
so we'll write here
dollar and then we'll access the image
so we'll write here
hash
one then we'll write here hover
we'll write here
funk1 and
fung2 so these are the two functions we
are going to create so next up let's
create these functions so we'll write
your function
func one this is our first function and
then inside this will write dollar
will access the image again so we'll
write here img1
dot css dot
okay dot css then we'll write here width
and the width is going to be
let's suppose 500 pixels for onmouseover
event and then we'll create another
function over here we'll write your
function funct2
now inside the body of this function
what we are going to do is we are going
to copy this piece of code from here and
then we'll paste it here fine now
instead of 500 pixels we want the image
to get back to its original form so
we'll write here
250 pixels only
so here we are we are done with the
programming part now save this program
and you can see it over here that we
have the exact same functionality like
that of mouse enter and mouse leave
events so the whole event works almost
the same
we'll look at different effects present
in jquery and we'll see how easy it is
to use those effects
let's start this video with a simple
definition of effects in layman terms an
effect refers to an event condition or
state of affairs produced by a cause for
example we click on a button on the
website and suddenly the image
disappears this refers to the fade in
effect and then we click on another
button and the image is back the fade
out effect right we have been through
such effects and animations previously
in the javascript part as well if you
guys remember we have the zoom in and
zoom out effects as well wherein we were
clicking on a button and the size of the
image changes to large and all of that
stuff refers to effects and animations i
hope you guys must have got an idea
about what we'll be doing in this
particular video first of all we'll add
an image to a html file and then we'll
use different effects on that particular
image the task is straightforward right
so let's move on to the programming part
directly now let's add an image over
here on the browser first we can create
a container as well but let's do it with
images only for now because it will be
easy and more understanding for you guys
so we'll go through the hide and show
effect first
so we'll add an image and three buttons
to our webpage
one for hiding another one for showing
and
last one for both so you will understand
it much better while working on them so
let's add the image and buttons over
here
we'll write here
img
src is going to be
images slash
j1.png
then we'll write here alt as
javascript so this is a basic image we
have in a images folder we'll write here
id as img1 for this image and the width
is let's say
250 pixels for this image fine
save this program and you can see the
image over here on the browser now the
next thing we are going to do is we are
going to add buttons as well so we'll
write here
button and let's say the id of this
button is going to be
btn1 for button one
will write here height
then we'll copy this statement from here
and we'll paste it three times
the button id is going to be two and
three
and the button name is going to be
show and
let's say the last button name is toggle
fine
so here we are we have an image over
here and three buttons for different
tasks what we want is we want to hide
the image by clicking on the hide button
and we want the image to get back on the
web page by clicking on the show button
fine so what we'll do here is we'll use
the
br tag as well so we will write here
br twice and here you can see we have
three buttons over here let me zoom it
out a bit
so we have three buttons over here hide
show and toggle so these three buttons
have three different ids btn one two and
three and we have an image over here
fine now let's move on to the jquery
part and we'll see how easy it is to
perform such tasks in jquery
so here is a javascript file and we have
the ready function over here already so
we'll write a code inside this
particular event only
now what we'll do is we'll write here
dollar
and then we'll write here
button1 will access this button with
idbtn1
then we'll write here click click is the
event
and we'll write your function and the
function is going to be an anonymous
function fine next up we'll write a
dollar
then we'll access
the image with id as img1
then we'll write here dot height
and that's it so what we did here was
easy we use the click event and hide
effect
hide here is actually a predefined
function in jquery that will make the
desired element completely hidden from
the web page so let's check the output
for this code first save the program
move to the browser
and click on the hide button over here
so you can see the image is completely
gone from the web page it's not present
here anymore
and you guys can see how easy it is to
perform such tasks in jquery because we
have a predefined function already
present in our jquery file isn't it
great we don't have to write long code
for a small task right all we need to do
is to write a single line of code and we
are good fine
so let's write the same code for the
show button as well now we need to
access the button with ids btn2 and the
action will change to show
so what we'll do here is we'll copy this
piece of code from here
and we'll paste it here again now
the next thing we'll be doing here is
we'll be changing the id to btn2
and the height function will change to
show here fine now save the program move
to the browser and you can see we have
both the buttons working over here if we
click on this height button the image is
hidden and if we click on this show
button you can see the image is here
again so these two buttons are working
totally fine you can see
if we click on the show button the image
is back here again
now if we want this task to be performed
after 2 seconds let's say we can say we
want the image to take 2 seconds to hide
and we know that in javascript we can
use the set time interval method or the
settimeout method something like that
but in jquery we have an easy
alternative for this so what we have to
do is we have to write here
inside this height action we'll write
here 2000 similarly we'll do the same
thing for show as well we'll write here
2000 now 2000 here refers to
two seconds fine
save the program
click on the hide button now and you can
see the image is taking two seconds to
get completely hidden similar thing will
happen with the show button as well if
we click on the show button you can see
the image takes two seconds for that as
well
so it's working totally fine right it
seems like the fade in and fade out
effects but there is a difference
between this effect and the fade in and
fade out effect we'll go through it in a
moment
for now what we'll do is we'll add
functionality to this toggle button over
here now this toggle button over here
has the capability to perform both tasks
using a single button what i mean by
that is we don't have to create two
separate buttons for hiding and showing
the image what we can do is we can also
use a single button for this task so
let's add functionality to this button
first and for that we'll write here
dollar the id for this toggle button is
hash btn3
then we'll write here dot click
and we are going to create an anonymous
function
now inside the body of this function
will again access the image
so we'll write here hash img1
then we'll write here dot
toggle fine
let's change the timing here let's say
we want this to take three seconds on
using the toggle button now save this
program click on the hide and show
button and you can see they are taking
two seconds to complete the task right
two seconds to hide the image and two
seconds to show the image again now the
toggle button will work differently but
the toggle button will do is on clicking
the toggle button it will take three
seconds to hide the image and if we
click on this button again you can see
after three seconds the image is back
here again fine the toggle function over
here is written in such a way that it
can perform the tasks of both the height
and the shoe functions
the time we mentioned here totally
depends upon us so we can either use it
or we can leave it as well now moving
ahead we have another type of effect
present in jquery which acts almost the
same as the hide and show functions but
the animations is slightly different
so we are talking about the fade in and
the fade out effects in jquery we'll go
through them now and we'll see the
difference between hide show toggle and
fade in fade out and fade toggle fine so
what we'll do is we'll add three more
buttons in a html file so that we can
witness the difference between all of
them so what we'll do is we'll copy this
piece of code from here
we'll paste it here
and we'll write here the button ids 4 5
and 6.
now the button names are going to be
fading and the second button is going to
be
fade out
and the last one is going to be
fade toggle fine
save the program
and you can see we have three more
buttons over here now you guys will get
confused but don't worry about it it's
an easy task
so what we'll do now is we'll use jquery
for fading in and out this particular
image
now the syntax will remain the same so
we'll move to a javascript file
and now what we'll do is we'll access
button four five and six which are fade
in fade out and fade toggle so we'll
write here
hash
btn 4
for the fade in button so we'll write
here dot
click
and on clicking we'll call an anonymous
function again
and then we'll access the image over
here so the image id is img1
then we'll write here dot
fade in and we'll
pass the timestamp as well so let's say
the timestamp is 2000 for this fade in
function
fine
now we'll do the same for fade out as
well so we'll copy this from here we'll
paste it here
the button id is going to be 5 and
instead of fade in we have
fade out over here
fine so we have to write here fade out
with a capital o and fade in with a
capital i
now we have written the code for both
fade in and fade out buttons here so
that it will not create any sort of
confusion for you guys
the fade out effects work the same as
the hide effect and the fade in effect
works the same way as the show effect
fine
so save this piece of code click on
height and you can see these functions
are working totally fine
the hide and show buttons are working
totally fine now click on this fade out
button and you can see the image fading
out in two seconds click on the fade in
button and the image is here back again
after two seconds
so these two buttons are working totally
fine
the fade toggle effect the last button
over here will write the code for this
button as well so this fit toggle effect
in jquery acts the same as the toggle
effect it can work like the fade in and
the fade out button so let's write the
code for that as well what we'll do is
we'll copy this piece of code from here
and we'll paste it here the button id is
6
and instead of fade out
we'll write here
fit
toggle fine
now save this program
and you can see the button over here is
working totally fine on clicking fade
toggle the image fades away after two
seconds or we can say it's taking two
seconds to fade away and on clicking the
sway toggle button again you can see the
image is here again
we can see the difference here as well
between the height show and fade in fade
out effects
the fade effect is different from the
other effect the syntax although seems
to be the same and no significant
differences in the syntax and the
working the only different thing is the
way of achieving the desired effect
you can see the difference by clicking
the button you can see on clicking the
hide effect the animation is different
from that in fade in or fade out effect
you can see there is a difference of
animations only
now let's move ahead and talk about
another effect in jquery
the upcoming effect will discuss is the
slide effect the syntax is same so let's
go through the slide effect quickly
now what we'll do is we'll add three
buttons and we'll discuss the slide
effect fine so what we'll do here is
let's remove these buttons
and
okay so let's do one thing let's remove
these three buttons
and we'll write here
id is 7
8 and
9. fine
and then we'll change the name of these
buttons so we'll write here
slide up
slide down
and
let's say
slide toggle fine now i hope you guys
must have understood the working of
slide toggle by now it will work in both
ways it will make the
image slide up and slide down at the
same time by using a single button so
don't worry about it we'll remove these
br tags from here and we'll paste them
here
save this program now and we have three
buttons over here slide up slide down
and slide toggle now what we'll do is
we'll remove this piece of code as well
i hope you guys must have got it by now
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to write the code for slide
effect
fine the syntax remains the same so we
will write here dollar
the button id is going to be btn7
for slide button for slide up button
we'll write here the click event and
we'll create a function over here
fine the task will remain the same we'll
write here again
img1 will access this particular image
and will write here
slide up
we want this image to take two seconds
to slide up so we'll write here 2000 as
the timestamp
now save this program and click on the
slide up button over here
you can see the image sliding in the
upward direction right now what we'll do
is we'll write the code for slide down
and slide toggle as well
so we'll write here button
8 for slide down
will right here slide down instead of
slide up
and we'll write here slide
toggle fine we'll write here btn 9 for
slide toggle
save the program and you can see on the
browser that all the buttons are working
totally fine if we click on slide up
button the slide up button is working
fine the slide down button is also
working fine and if we click on the
slide toggle button you can see the
image is sliding up and down as well so
before wrapping up this video now let me
tell you guys about the stop method as
well so what we'll do is we'll add
another stop button on our webpage we'll
move to a html file
will copy this particular statement from
here
we'll change the name of this button to
stop
and the button add is going to be btn10
fine save this program now
we'll move to a javascript file and
we'll write here
dollar will access this stop button so
we'll write here btn10
dot click
and we'll create a function over here
now inside this function will write hash
img1
will access this image and then we'll
write here
dot stop so we are calling a function
over here so stop is a function
basically now save the program and move
to the browser now you can see if we
click on this stop button when the
effect is taking place
so if we click on this slider button and
then in between we click on this stop
button you can see the difference over
here we can slide down the image from
here and
we can do the same thing
with the stop button so what stop button
is doing is it stops the effect in
between
right
you can see all the buttons over here
are working totally fine and we can
stop this effect in between right
so this is why we use jquery for such
tedious tasks a single line of code can
do it so quickly and so easily right
so these are some of the significant
effects we have in jquery and they are
pretty easy to use as well
we are going to discuss the jquery
animate effect
we discussed jquery effects and we know
how to use certain effects like fade in
fade out and the scroll up scroll down
effect to make changes in html documents
today we'll take a look at the jquery
animate effect in particular here's the
code from the last part wherein we use
the scroll effect in an image
the image slides up on clicking the
slide up button
and the image slides down on clicking
the slide down button we can also stop
the sliding effect in between by
clicking on this stop button as well so
far we have been using these effects to
make our web pages more interactive
right
now this animate effect we'll use in
today's video is a bit different from
these effects the animate effect uses
css properties and it can be used to
make an image or an object like a
rectangle or something move across the
web page in a particular manner
seems confusing right so let's start
writing the code and everything will be
clear to you guys we'll be using an
image for this task so let's remove all
this code from here first we'll write
the code again
now we'll remove this code from here
and we'll write the code again so let's
add the image over here and then we'll
style that image using the style tag
only so we will write here
div will be using a container for this
inside this will write img
now src is going to be images
slash
j1.png so we'll be using the same image
for this task
then we'll write here alt
so let's say we are writing here
something and then we'll write here ids
img let's say fine
let's close this image tag save the
program now and you can see the image
over here the image size is quite large
we can reduce the size of a chrome
browser so you can see this is the image
now what we'll do next is we'll style
this image using the style tag so let's
style this image as well here we'll move
to a head tag and we'll write here
style
fine
now inside the style tag we'll access
this image using the image id so id for
this image is img we'll write here img
and then inside this will write some
properties over here so let's define the
height of this image first
let's say the height is going to be 250
pixels
then we'll write here
width as well so let's say the width is
again 250 pixels
and we'll use opacity over here fine
we'll write here opacity is equals to
let's say 0.4
we'll discuss it later why we are using
opacity here
now the last thing we are going to do is
we are going to write here position as
absolute
so opacity here will define the fading
effect of this image save this program
and you can see it here on the browser
we have a picture with an opacity of 0.4
it's obviously different from the actual
image let's increase the size of this
image for now
so here is the image
now the next thing we'll be doing is
we'll be adding a button over here to
call the animate effect for that we'll
write here after this
button and the button id is going to be
let's say btn
then we'll write here the name of our
button is let's say animate
save this piece of code and you can see
we have the animate button over here
we'll use the br tag to create some
distance between the button and the
image so save this program and you can
see over here that we have a button and
an image
now we'll use the animate effect to make
this picture move across the browser or
we can say across the container
so we'll use the click event for the
animate button
now let's move on to the jquery part
here we are in the jquery part we'll
remove this piece of code and now we'll
try to access this animate button using
the button id fine so for that we'll
write here dollar
inside this we'll write
btn so this is our button id
and then we'll write here dot click we
are going to use the click event over
here
then we'll create an anonymous function
this task is easy and here we are we
have used the click event here so the
next thing we'll be doing is to use the
animate effect now so for that we'll
write here
dollar now we are going to use this
animate effect over a image so the image
id is img and then we'll write it dot
animate
and we'll leave it for now
now this animate effect over here has
three different parameters the first one
are going to be the css properties the
style changes we are going to create on
a picture so we'll write those changes
inside the curly braces the second
parameter is the timestamp
and let's say we are using 2000 over
here so 2000 over here is the
milliseconds
now the third parameter which is the
callback we'll be discussing callback in
the upcoming videos for now we'll use
these two parameters only
now let's move ahead and we'll write the
css properties here inside these curly
braces
so we'll write over here let's say we
are writing here left
and we'll write here left as
150 pixels fine
now this left property over here will
take the image 150 pixels away from the
left side of the container
so save this program and now you can
witness the changes on this web page
click on the animate button
and you can see the image slides over to
the right corner the animation takes two
seconds to complete because we have
given the timestamp here as 2000
milliseconds let's reduce the size of
this chrome browser a bit and now you
can see it properly refresh the page and
we'll click on this animate button and
you can see the image slides over the
effect is working fine let's make some
more changes to this image style by
clicking the animate button
all we have to do is to add some more
css properties to this animate effect
and for that we'll write here some more
properties with the help of commas only
so we'll put a comma over here and we'll
write here let's say
opacity so we'll change the opacity of
this image to
1
then we'll again use the comma and
change the height and width as well so
let's say the height is going to be 400
pixels
and then we'll write here width as well
fine so width is going to be again 400
pixels
so we are done with it now the height
and width of this image will change to
400 pixels along with the opacity
changing to one
it means that the image will be
completely opaque after clicking on the
animate button save this program now and
move to the browser click on the animate
button here to see the magic now
you can see the size of the image
increasing gradually here in 2 seconds
however this animate method does not
have any toggle function though so we
can't retrieve the changes just by
clicking on the button again let me
reduce the size a bit more so that it
will be easy for you guys to understand
this effect
here we are we have this effect click on
the animate button and you can see the
change now
from opacity as 0.4 to opacity as 1.
there are some changes in the animations
right so this is what animate effect
does in jquery
now instead of writing here 2000 what we
can do is we can write here slow or fast
so let's try doing it as well what we'll
do is we'll write here instead of 2000
we'll write here slow for now so we'll
write here slow save this program click
on the animate button again and you can
see the change
so it's not taking two seconds anymore
now the slow keyword will work and the
animation effect will change fine
and with that we come to the end of this
jquery basics tutorial if you enjoyed
watching the video do give it a thumbs
up comment your doubts below and our
experts will answer them for you thank
you so much for being here watch out for
more videos from us until then keep
learning and stay tuned to simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here